i i feel uh very sad about what what
just happened in new zealand right
may allah reward them to figure those
and without any heats up
so we're in new york this is new york
queens
how are you doing brother we're at
masjid he's having the jesus son of mary
mosque look at that that's amazing we
even got a mosque named after
one of the greatest messengers ever sent
to mankind jesus this is the mosque
named after jesus right that's right
that's right we named it the jesus son
of mary moss so that when people
walk on the streets they would realize
that islam you know believes in jesus
believes in the messenger and you
wouldn't believe we have a lot of people
that actually walk into the mosque
out of the blue and say just because i
saw the sign i wanted to find out more
information we actually had a lot of
people accept islam because of it as
well
there you go i mean do you think this
person that this terrorist
do you think this terrorist knew how
much love
because recently you had this terrorist
attack that killed
i believe almost 50 innocent human
beings
you know in a place of worship like this
this is uh this is something similar to
where they were at worshiping the one
god do you think this terrorist
had any idea on what islam is you know
this love they have for jesus
you know besides all this you know
misinformation that people have that
pumps them up to go do crazy stuff like
that
yeah i mean first definitely condolences
and prayers go out to all the family and
all the injured
you know make it easy for them for their
families may god almighty you know ease
all of their affairs
and you know allow their families to be
okay after this horrific incident and
you know as you said it's a terrorist
it's a terrorist attack i mean it's an
attack of extremism
and it's you know i'm sure that he
didn't know what true islam is
you know if he had walked into a mosque
spoke to somebody
you know they probably would have took
him out to dinner you know educated him
on what the truth is
about islam and it would have done
wonders for him
and um you know it's you know an
incident like this is a wake-up call
also for us you know sometimes as
muslims
we're in our bubbles you know and we're
not doing enough to go out
and interact with people and educate
people about islam you know you think
about it as you're watching this video
right now when's the last time you
talked to someone about islam
probably years ago you know so we have a
lot of work to do you know in front of
us and it's a reminder calling a wake-up
call for us as well
i heard that the the brother the muslim
who was at the door
one of his last words was calling this
terrorist who has come in because that's
the
the the brotherhood that you you get
from the muslim he was he was saying hey
brother like he thought that
his last words i was reading a post he
said uh hey bro
brother and then he ended up getting
gunned down by this terrorist
that's just yeah i mean i haven't read
that specifically but look in islam
there's a brotherhood based on religion
and faith but there's also a brotherhood
in humanity i mean we're all human
beings
we all have families we all have wants
and needs and
you know we all enjoy doing certain
things so we definitely got to start
connecting with other people
and interacting and talking to people
you know and educating them that that
way
let me let me ask you what do you think
because obviously
this does not represent christianity of
course anytime
someone walks past the muslim you know
is connected somehow
to islam the religion gets brought into
it
nowhere have you been brought and we're
not saying that it should be but it
should be fair and balanced but what do
you
what do you think now because obviously
if you want to look into his roots he's
obviously christian
yes he he's somebody who's also playing
an anthem of a song
that back in serbia they have a
specific group of people called the
chetniks and
they had committed atrocities and you
know one of the worst genocides after
the worst genocide after world war ii
they were doing a crusade against
muslims and
now he was singing that song you know
he was playing that song so he's
obviously linked to christianity we
don't blame christianity we want people
to be fair and balanced but what do you
think now but his religion is not
brought up
at all and usually when muslim someone's
attributed to
to being a muslim islam is put on trial
yeah i mean look there's there are
extremists in every faith in every walk
of life
right you know if you look at
christianity there's extremists if you
look at muslims there are extremists we
have to admit that if you look at
judaism there's extremists if you look
at atheism there's extremists right
we can't fall into the trap of
linking the action of an extremist to a
specific faith
right we can't we can't say that the
entire faith is now extremism because
that's what they do to us
and that hurts us right and that's the
whole thing that we're going against
right
so you know for us we have to
we have to be the better people we have
to educate it's all about education
right we have to educate people that
listen the action of one does not define
a faith you know if you look at islam
you got one point what six seven eight
billion muslims worldwide well guess
what if islam was based on a religion of
extremism
what that means is that the world would
have been destroyed by now right so we
can't say that
islam leads to terrorism and destruction
we can't say that but we also can't say
that about their faiths also
you see how that's fair and balanced you
see how that's fair and balanced and
that's we're calling
all the time fair and balance balance
and our
condolences and prayers go out to all
the victims of this terrorist attack and
may god almighty allah
grant them jannah uh really sad
for i mean this thing to happen uh with
the brothers and sisters
i wish we could help them but i mean you
know
we just want to remember them in our
prayers and
you know all our hearts goes for them
and
i hope you know
god gave allah gave their relatives
as a suburb and uh you know
inshallah will work with the uh people
who are uh who think that our religion
is not about peace
inshallah our message will go go through
and they will understand what the islam
is all about
so thank you hello
which is as from the hadith say of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam is a
good day to die
and then you know alhamdulillah they was
in the mouth they were in the masjid
so and allah says in the quran he says
for verily do not say they are dead
he said for verily say they are alive
and they are with their lord
the death so may allah make them of them
i mean dr jamila jones allah is in
control of everything
put your trust in faith in allah
wholeheartedly that's my advice
i'm very upset about the events that
have taken place
and um i always ask people to just go
back to
their trust and their faith in the law
and that
for every after every difficulty there
is ease so that's that's my mention no
specific duel but just to remember
constantly remember reflect and ponder
that after every difficulty there comes
and that the people who who have passed
away
are the martyrs and they're not dead
they're with the law
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the instructors here at masjid is
what was your response to did you hear
the news of what happened this tragic
terrorist attack i mean i heard a bit
about it you know it's just really
unfortunate that people will do
something like that
and um i mean my advice is for myself
and everybody is just
you know make sure that you you know
keep your composure you know and not
to act emotionally um and just wait for
the details you know we wait before
making assumptions
and um and statements about it you know
be very careful
and i mean my biggest advice is just to
make the art for the people
you know that uh send out doors to those
people as allah to forgive them
and to make it easy for the families
because you know
this was just i mean from what i've
heard on the news it's just something
out of
out of the ordinary or something you
know out of nowhere that this happened
so um
you know stay with you know vigilance
stay you know protective over your
families
and uh just mcdonald for them you know
and if you're able to help these
families in whatever
way you can i mean i think that's
something that we should all definitely
do
you know at first of course you're
stricken with sadness
you're sticking with grief but as you
say
we have to have patience and we pray for
them
we cannot act with anger uh
all part of allah's plan even though
it's something that to us right now it's
it's very hard to swallow when you see
something like that
because it's it's injustice you know and
the best thing that we can do is our
family's patience
and do the best that we can to continue
propagating this message of islam
because no matter what it will always
survive and it will always thrive
one thing that you know i've been
thinking about a lot is that you know
obviously
the this terrorist actions were recorded
and you know he recorded a live video
and a lot of us are you know actually
sharing this video around
you know i don't think we should be
sharing this video because
his actions were limited to those
individuals in that
locality right and you know it was
horrific what happened in new zealand
but by sharing
this video especially for our brothers
and sisters muslims by sharing this
video we're now spreading that fear
to muslims all over the place you know
you're going to have muslim women muslim
children who are going to be scared to
profess their faith so just my word of
advice you know i i would humbly suggest
don't share the video there's no point
in it another thing what advice would
you give also for the you know
those people who get also who are not
well grounded in the dean
or they also they end up using this
as opportunity we there is that small
fringe element
that can go ahead and use this excuse to
go ahead and do something maybe
perpetuate something that there's no
justification for it in islam
and they might want to go ahead and do
something as a as a revenge what advice
would you have
yeah islam prohibits murder the islam
prohibits
killing of innocent individuals um so
we have to be better than that um we
don't stoop
to those lows that some extremists and
some terrorists will do we have to be
better than that and if you look at the
life
the life example of the prophet isaiah
peace and blessings be upon the prophet
muhammad
his whole life exemplified that so many
people did harsh things to him but he
always went higher and treated them
better and because of that
1.78 billion muslims now exist right so
we have to be better than that
and you know one last point i would also
mention is that some of us who might be
weakened
you know a little bit weaker in faith we
all have our weaknesses
see an incident like this and might want
to you know say well
you know forget islam i'm not practicing
anymore um you know my word of advice
you know for for those who might be
feeling heartbroken and perhaps want to
leave their faith is that
in islam the true judgment is on the day
of judgment so no matter what happens on
this earth
god the almighty the all-wise the
all-just
will have that justice done on the day
of judgment
so the believer can have their heart you
know eased
at that sense of comfort that is
definitely a sense of comfort knowing
that there's a day of judgment and god
almighty
allah put everything in place back then
be patient
wake up for fajr make sure you live in
islam
get grounded in it and it gives you the
tools on how to handle all these
situations but most of all put your
trust
in the crater that happens in the earth
we'll see you next time peace salaam
alaikum